je suis parti sur les traces du plus
grandes magicien de tous les temps celui
grâce à qui la magie et ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui celui qui a controversé
l'illusion et les prestides digitateurs
et inspirez les plus grands
illusionnistes de notre siècle son père
fondateur jeune homme
mesdames et messieurs bienvenue dans
l'antre de la prestidigitation quel que
soit l'image que vous ayez de la
prestidigitation de l'illusionnisme et
tout ce qui touche à l'univers de la
magie Robert Houda en est le père
fondateur vous allez découvrir comment
cette horloger a révolutionné la magie
inspirez les plus grands illusionnistes
que le monde est connu au point même que
le célèbre Harry Houdini est choisi ce
nom de scène en hommage à Robert houden
qui est-il comment a-t-il réussi à
renverser les codes de la magie au point
d'en être encore la référence
aujourd'hui vous allez le découvrir
maintenant
nous allons commencer ce chapitre par le
moment le plus insolite de ce
documentaire nous sommes en 1856 et la
France colonise l'Algérie depuis
maintenant 26 ans nous ne nous
attarderons pas sur le côté regrettable
et funeste de cette période historique
mais uniquement sur les intentions
pacifistes qui avaient Robert Houdin
avec son illusionniste
Robert Houdain est le plus célèbre
prestigeateur de France mais aussi des
pays alentours il sait déjà produit
devant la reine d'Angleterre le roi
Louis-Philippe premier et possède son
théâtre au palais royal qui fait ça le
comble
nous sommes sous le règne de Napoléon
III depuis quatre ans la France contrôle
l'Algérie à l'exception de la Kabylie
une population n'a soumis se révolte et
donne lieu à de nombreux conflits armés
des Algériens et les soldats français
ils laissent leur vie la situation n'est
plus tenable pour y remédier ils font
appel à Robert Houdin
on l'avait appelé pour mystifier les
marabouts parce que les marabouts là-bas
dans ces pays algériens et africains ils
avaient un pouvoir énorme sur la
population
à l'époque les marabouts étaient
considérés comme une bénédiction des
dieux il disait pouvoir réaliser des
prodiges et leur influence était donc
parole d'évangile non seulement il
détenait une grande partie du pouvoir
civil et religieux mais il n’hésitez pas
à se servir de tour d'illusion pour
convaincre la population de leur pouvoir
surnaturel
il est évident que les marabouts
n'avaient aucun pouvoir ésotérique et
que tout cela n'était possible que grâce
à une manipulation astucieuse et prenez
un poulet et lui couper la tête et
prenez la tête ensanglanter
il reprenait la tête il a remettez
dessus et hop et le poulet ou le canard
remarqué
alors les gens ils étaient voilà crédule
et il disait si vous m'écoutez pas je
peux arriver à faire des miracles et ça
peut se retourner contre vous et les
gens étaient terrorisés une tête de
poule de canard est tellement flexible
qu'on peut tout simplement la plier et
la cacher sous l'aile donc voilà et vous
tenez votre canard comme ça il a pas de
tête en fait il a la tête caché sous
l'aile ça lui fait pas mal juste comme
ça et recouvert et vous prenez
évidemment avec une petite manipulation
une autre tête de poule de la même
couleur que la couleur originale et
voilà vous la tenez comme ça vous faites
semblant de la couper un peu d'éponge un
peu avec du sang dedans ça coule voilà
on a la tête et autres petites
manipulation on échange on libère et la
tête la véritable tête le gouvernement
demande alors à Robert Oudin de se
rendre en Algérie pour montrer qu'ils
ont un sorcier plus puissant que leur
marabout Robert Houdain refusera de
participer à ce conflit politique durant
deux années consécutives parce qu'il
était très connu en France
tout le monde s'arrache et ses places
pour aller voir ce phénomène d'un
magicien qui faisait des miracles dans
ces soirées fantastiques et donc
évidemment c'est arrivé aux oreilles de
des gouvernants qui étaient à l'époque
il avait eu cette mission d'aller
démystifier les les
marabes la troisième année le général
neveu décrit à Robert Houdin une
manipulation effroyable des marabouts
sur leur population rebelle le marabout
chargé un fusible prononçait quelque
parole kabbalistiques et tiré sur le
rebelle sans qu'aucune balle ne le
touche ainsi il se croyait immunisé face
au bal évidemment ce procédé de
manipulation avait pour seul but de les
pousser à combattre face à l'armée
française et lieu hélas de nombreux
morts lorsque le célèbre magicien entend
cela il reconnaît tout de suite un tour
d'illusion qu'il pratique lui-même dans
son théâtre à savoir le fusil est vivant
comprenant la supercherie dans son
victime les rebelles et encouragés par
le gouvernement persuadé que son
intervention pourrait sauver des vies
Houdain accepte infinie de partir en
mission pour l'État
le 28 et le 29 octobre 1856 le maréchal
Randon convoque au théâtre d'Alger tous
les chefs arabes du territoire afin
qu'ils assistent le spectacle du sorcier
blanc Robert roudin en réalité il ne
s'agit pas de marabout mais de
fonctionnaires algériens qui recevaient
la protection de la France mais qui
pouvait toutefois avoir une influence
notable sur les populations rebelles
trois tours de magie ont
particulièrement stupéfié l'assemblée
faisant parler de Robert Houdin dans
tout le pays jusque dans les zones
reculées ou sévisser les marins
avait un tour qui s'appelait le coffre
lourd et léger lorsqu'il se produit à
Paris il pose un petit coffre en bois au
sol contenant tous ses objets de valeur
et racontent qu'aucun voleur ne peut le
subtiliser tant ce coffre est lourd mais
lorsqu'il se produit en Algérie il
l'adapte en fonction de la mission qui
lui a été donné amenez-moi le plus fort
des guerrières algériens je vais lui
prendre sa force et le rendre aussi
faible qu'un enfant
[Musique]
afin que le coffre soit impossible à
soulever ou d'un avait trouvé l'astuce
de placer un électro-aimant sous la
Seine
[Applaudissements]
le deuxième tour consiste à faire
disparaître un individu sous les yeux
médusés du public il s'agit de la
disparition sous le gobelet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce numéro créé tant de frayeur que la
salle se vida en quelques instants ou
d'un pour cette expérience avait fait
appel à un compère disparu en réalité
par une trappe
le troisième tour et le fusilier vivant
rappelez-vous c'est celui même que les
marabouts opérés sur les rebelles pour
les convaincre qu'ils étaient immortels
face au bal de l'armée française ce tour
là ou d'un va devoir le refaire au cours
de son expédition en Algérie mais cette
fois au péril de sa vie alors qu'il
devait rentrer en France les généraux
français demandent à Houda de partir à
la rencontre des tribus insoumises
replié dans les montagnes c'est ainsi
que Houdain et sa femme Olympe partir 12
jours dans le désert à la rencontre de
vrais marabouts la réputation de grands
sorciers dont pouvait se vêtir désormais
ou d'un était revenu aux oreilles des
marabouts qui le voyait d'un très
mauvaise oeil en effet Houdain révèle
aux insurgés les secrets astucieux de
leur sorcier afin de leur faire perdre
toute crédibilité leur pouvoir est en
remis en cause les insoumis se montrent
de plus en plus méfiants et moins
prompte à leurs obéir mais l'un d'eux se
montre à plus difficile impressionné
Abderrahman un sorcier très influent
auprès des insoumis et convaincu que
Houtain est un imposteur qui a
empoisonné les spectateurs d'Alger
lorsque le magicien se rend jusqu'à lui
dans un lieu reculé du désert
Abderrahman lui donne alors un défi il
veut tirer sur Robert Houdain comme il
l'a fait lors de ses représentations à
Alger ce tour c'est le fusil et vivant
et il a en effet fait couler beaucoup
d'encre après son passage à la
différence cap d'agaraman veut qu'il le
fasse avec ses propres pistolets et non
ceux du magicien bien que le procédé
exact de Robert Oudin porte ce tour
reste par certains aspects encore
mystérieux la proposition du marabout le
mis dans une réelle difficulté ou d'un
prétexta avoir oublié son talisman à
Alger et de voir prier toute la nuit
afin de compenser ce manque en réalité
ou d'un passe la nuit à trouver un
subterfuge tandis que sa femme Olympe le
supplie de refuser ce défi mais pour le
magicien il est hors de question de
reculer
le lendemain matin tout le monde est
présent à l'heure du rendez-vous
Abderrahmane temps à Houdeng ces deux
pistolets et des balles en plomb afin
qu'il les charges lui-même sous ses yeux
Abderrahman observe minutieusement
chacun de ses gestes à l'affût d'une
supercherie ou d'un s'exécute et se
place 15 pas devant lui
le sorcier prend alors un premier
pistolet et le vise le coup part
et la balle apparaît entre les dents de
Houdain
Abderrahmane se précipite vers le
deuxième fusil mais où dans le devant et
lui dit tu vas pouvoir juger maintenant
si mes coups sont plus redoutables que
les tiens
[Musique]
tout le monde acclame Houdain tandis que
le sorcier est vaincu en réalité Houda a
fabriqué deux fausses balles avec la
cire d'une bougie la deuxième balle
était elle remplit de son sang en
chargeant les pistolets le magicien est
parvenu à échanger les balles en plomb
avec celle qu'il avait confectionné
grâce à ses talents de prestidigitateur
ou d'un prix un risque considérable ce
jour-là sans doute le plus gros de toute
son existence Robert houden et sa femme
pouvaient enfin reprendre le chemin de
la France après ce dernier périple
boudin repartira avec ce qu'il dira
peut-être la plus belle récompense de sa
vie au palais du gouverneur à Alger
s'est tenu une délégation des chefs de
tribus arabes pour lui remettre un
diplôme le reconnaissant comme étant le
plus grand des magiciens
gloire à Dieu qui enseigne ce que l'on
ignore qui rend sensible les trésors de
la pensée par les fleurs de l'éloquence
et les signes de l'écriture le destin ou
généreusement du milieu des éclairs et
du tonnerre a fait tomber d'en haut
comme une pluie forte et bienfaisante la
merveilleuse du moment et du siècle
celui qui cultive des arts surprenants
et des sciences merveilleuses
Robert Oudin il a su remuer nos cœurs
étonné nos esprits en nous montrant les
faits surprenant de sa science
merveilleuse pardonne-nous de te
présenter si peu à un marchand on donne
de l'or à toi Robert Houdain nous te
présentons un hommage que tu pourras
léguer à tes enfants
pardonne-nous de te donner si peu mais
convient-il d'offrir le nacre à celui
qui possède la perle
lors de son retour sa première escale se
fait à Marseille où il annoncera dans
son théâtre national se produire pour la
dernière fois mettant ainsi un terme à
sa carrière d'illusionniste
[Applaudissements]
mais l'histoire en décidera autrement
Robert Houdain retrouvera le chemin de
la scène quelques années plus tard pour
détourner exceptionnel
[Musique]
nous venons de voir que la magie n'a pas
toujours été employée comme un
divertissement tel que nous le
connaissons mais à d'autres dessins et
souvent dépourvu de tous en moral et si
les marabouts profitaient de leur statut
pour abuser de la naïveté de la
population ce ne sont ni les premiers ni
les seuls à avoir usé de ce procéder
depuis que le monde est né la magie
existe c'est elle est historiquement
elle remonte à la nuit des temps donc
les sorciers faisaient des tours déjà ce
qui est sûr c'est que la magie est née
d'une volonté de certains hommes à en
manipuler d'autres avec une connaissance
particulière que les autres n'avaient
pas c'est ça le point de départ de la
manipulation de l'homme sur l'homme avec
une connaissance que seuls certains
avaient ils prétendaient avoir des des
pouvoirs ce qui leur amenait un
ascendant sur les autres le plus vieux
tour de magie dont nous avons retrouvé
la trace remonte à 2000 ans avant
Jésus-Christ en Égypte un dénommé dédit
de Disney fut tranche la tête d'un
canard et d'un pélican et arrive ensuite
à reconstituer chacun des animaux sans
leur faire le moindre mal oui c'est
exactement le même procédé utilisé par
les marabouts que nous venons d'explorer
dans le premier chapitre mais imaginez
le choc que cela a pu représenter à
l'époque pour la population il y avait
effectivement la manipulation de l'homme
sur l'homme avec un pouvoir qu'on
expliquait pas qu'on essayait de garder
secret qu'on qu'on conservait en
cachette les premiers objets truqués
retrouvés à ce jour sont des vases de la
graisse antique remontant au sixième
siècle avant Jésus-Christ au premier
siècle après Jésus-Christ
héron d'alexandrey un grand ingénieur et
mathématicien invente la machine à
vapeur il parvint grâce à celle-ci à
ouvrir les portes d'un temple sans
aucune manipulation humaine hormis celle
de la vapeur alors qu'il était facile
pour héron de faire croire à des
pouvoirs surnaturels il a en réalité été
le premier à relater des trucages
utilisés dans les temples grecs
[Musique]
ce n'est qu'en 1819 qui est créé le
terme de prestidigitation qui signifie
l'agilité des doigts terme qui est venu
mettre en lumière la dextérité
nécessaire en magicien pour parvenir à
donner l'illusion d'un pouvoir magique
au Moyen-Âge il y avait les bateleur qui
avec des jeux de gobelets ou de cartes
se produisaient sur des étals dans la
rue et en profiter avec la complicité de
compère pour voler la bourse des gens à
leur insu ou encore les inciter à faire
des paris
[Musique]
ce 10 spectacle avait pour seul objectif
de voler l'argent des spectateurs et
hélas encore pratiqué de nos jours si
les contenus que le tour des bateleur
relevés de la prestidigitation et non
d'un pouvoir ésotérique ils étaient
toutefois qualifiés de diaboliques et
lieu de nombreux procès les accusant de
sorcellerie et les conduisant tout droit
à la mort et puis ensuite
cette manipulation s'est habillée de de
code avec des chapeaux pointus de codes
de magiciens dans le vrai sens du mot
c'est à dire que avant lui il y avait
des Merlin l'enchanteur avec des barbes
des chapeaux pointus des Caps des
étoiles voyez un peu comme Merlin
l'enchanteur des escamoteurs qui étaient
obligés de se cacher derrière un
accoutrement et surtout ils utilisaient
des objets qui n'appartenaient qu'à la
magie c'est à dire des anneaux des tubes
chromés des des casseroles bizarres des
accessoires qui n'appartenaient qu'aux
magicien la magie était plutôt vu comme
une curiosité un divertissement qu'on
pouvait voir parfois dans les rues
faites par des amuseurs publics par
exemple donc c'était vraiment pas
quelque chose qu'on considérait
d'artistique à cette époque j'engen
Robert n'a pas encore ajouté le nom de
Houdain à son patronyme et ignore qu'une
carrière d'illusionniste latent il est
horlogé de père en fils dans sa ville
natale de Blois et se passionne pour les
mécanismes de l'horlogerie des automates
jusqu'au jour où la magie est entrée
dans sa vie par un heureux concours de
circonstances alors en fait il est
devenu magicien très tardivement c'était
une erreur je pense une erreur il a
voulu il a commandé un livre sur
l'horlogerie
à son bibliothécaire là-bas
et il a reçu un livre sur la
précipitation
et il a découvert ça vraiment assez
tardivement et ça la fasciné alors non
seulement c'était déjà un horloger hors
pair mais en plus de ça il a été fasciné
par tous ces matériels à l'époque il y
avait des gobelets trucs qui est des
pièces trucs c'est en effet le traité de
l'horlogerie que Jean Eugène Robert avec
commandé et ce sont avec deux volumes
sur la prestidigitation qu'il ressortit
du bouquiniste ou d'un écrira dans ses
Mémoires je découvrais les secrets d'un
art pour lequel j'avais un monde insu
plus que de la vocation dès cet instant
l'horloger se fascine pour l'art de
l'illusion et se met en quête d'en
découvrir chacun de ces secrets à 24 ans
Jean Eugène Robert monte à Paris pour
épouser Cécile Eglantines ou d'un la
fille d'un horloger parisien il quitte
donc la ville de Blois pour s'installer
dans la capitale près de son épouse et
travaille dans l'horlogerie de son
beau-père
c'est alors qu'il décide d'ajouter le
nom de sa femme au sien et devient Jean
Eugène Robert Houdin
il devient très vite une référence dans
les réparation des automates et des
horloges si bien que le Tout-Paris fait
appel à ses services lorsqu'il s'agit de
réparer les mécanismes les plus
complexes cette nouvelle vie parisienne
va lui permettre d'arpenter les rues de
Paris et de découvrir ce qu'on appelait
à l'époque les spectacles de curiosité
danseurs de cordes exhibition de tomates
ou encore illusion d'optique Robert
Houdin part à la rencontre de ce qu'il
appellera des professeurs de magie
blanche afin d'affiner sa pratique de la
prestidigitation et c'est en observant
les figures importantes de la magie de
l'époque qu'il décèlera de nombreux
secrets le célèbre magicien Robin crée
des tours autour du spiritisme et
effraie son Assemblée Bosco tu des
volatile sur scène en les étouffant ou
en leur coupant la tête tout en saignant
de les ressusciter ou encore le
physicien compte qui a accès ses tours
sur les enfants prodiges avec lesquels
il se montrait très dur voire humiliant
inspiré et fascinés par l'illusion
Robert Houdin se rêve prestidigitateur
toutefois il ne se reconnaissait pas
dans la magie telle qu'elle était
pratiquée que ce soit dans le procédé le
costume ou encore la publicité tapageuse
qu'il avait en horreur cet univers ne
correspondait pas à sa personnalité et à
l'une de ces grandes passions les
sciences
Robert Houdin c'est surtout fait
connaître comme comme magicien mais il
était un redoutable scientifique qui l'a
d'ailleurs plusieurs inventions à son
nom il détenait plusieurs brevets
surtout lié à l'électricité en effet
Robert Houdan est avant tout un érudit
des sciences et déposera en l'espace de
7 ans plus de 37 brevets nous parlerons
de ses plus grandes inventions dans la
suite mais laissez-moi vous parler
maintenant de celles qui ont permis à
Houdain de voir toute la bourgeoisie
parisienne venir jusqu'à lui et qui
jouera un rôle prédominant dans le
lancement de sa carrière de magicien la
première est le réveil briquet à cette
époque il n'y avait pas d'électricité et
le seul moyen de s'éclairer était la
bougie ou encore la lampe à pétrole ou
d'un créer un réveil qui lorsque le
carillon sonne alors choisi fait sortir
une allumette pour enflammer la bougie
afin d'apporter la lumière sans avoir à
tâtonner dans le noir
[Musique]
et ce qui permet de faire rêver de
crédibiliser la magie et de faire rêver
une clientèle adulte donc de faire de la
magie quelque chose qui est pas qui est
pas Clooney qui est pas un
divertissement pour enfants qui est
vraiment quelque chose devant lequel
tout le monde peut s'émerveiller grâce à
ses connaissances scientifiques Robert
Houdin crée également des automates qui
émerveillaient aussi bien les adultes
que les enfants l'écrivain dessinateur
qui répondait à n'importe quelle
question que vous lui posiez la leçon de
chant l'escamoteur chinois est beaucoup
d'autres ont fasciné ses clients
[Musique]
c'est à ce moment là que Robert roudain
sans le savoir renverse tous les codes
de la magie au point de devenir le
fondateur de la magie moderne
Robert Houdin
était on avance sur son temps puisque
dans le monde de la magie on parle
toujours d'un avant Robert Houdain et
d'un après Robert Rodin c'est le premier
qui a dit stop on arrête de
manipuler les gens les autres de le
laisser entendre des éventuels pouvoirs
qui ne sont pas tout à fait vrai et on
met une tenue de soirée
on devient quelqu'un de normal et on
prétend qu'on fait un spectacle dans ces
soirées privées ou d'un semelle à la
haute bourgeoisie comme un homme du
monde avec pour seul instrument ses
mains la magie qu'il employait et celle
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le close-up et
c'est le début d'une ascension
remarquable qui prend forme dans la vie
de Robert Houdin il savait pénétrer dans
leur univers avec un verbe subtil une
élégance rare et un esprit fin qui
prenait le temps de raconter des
histoires pour introduire ses tours
Robert Houdain était sans le savoir en
train de préparer ce qui allait devenir
les soirées fantastiques son futur
spectacle qui allait faire de lui une
célébrité à travers le monde et
référence encore cité aujourd'hui son
succès lors des soirées privées est-elle
qu'il croulent littéralement sur les
demandes des particuliers grâce à cela
ils tentent des liens d'amitié avec des
personnes influentes de la haute
bourgeoisie qui l’incite à ouvrir son
propre théâtre pour lancer sa carrière
d'illusionniste Robert Houdin et songe
de plus en plus de plus en plus
sérieusement et commence à élaborer des
stratégies tactiques et financières pour
réaliser son rêve mais alors qui
s'approche du but un drame arrive
anéantit le magicien et met un coup
d'arrêt au rêve qui s'apprêtait à vivre
[Rires]
[Musique]
sa femme Cécile Eglantine et poussent
tant aimé qui lui a offert le nom de
Houdain dont gravement malade
[Rires]
après cette grossesse et la mort de
quatre enfants Cécile Eglantine a une
santé très fragile et meurt d'épuisement
à seulement 32 ans
Robert Houdain était rassé par le
chagrin il se retrouve alors seul avec
ses trois enfants de 6,7 et 12 ans dont
il confie les deux plus jeunes à ses
parents vivant toujours à Blois Émile
l'aîné reste près de lui à Paris
seulement Marie Rosalie la fille de
Robert Houdin meurt un an plus tard
prospère Robert le père de Robert Houdin
affligé de douleur par la rejoindre le
même jour ou d'un garde le nom de sa
défunte épouse et fait la rencontre
d'olham braconnier sa seconde femme
fille d'un illustre horloger qui
l'encourage vivement à quitter
l'horlogerie pour ouvrir son propre
théâtre et se lancer enfin comme
illusionniste deux ans plus tard soit le
3 juillet 1845 le monde de la magie
s'apprête à vivre une véritable
révolution Robert Houdin donne la
première représentation de son spectacle
les soirées fantastiques dans son
théâtre au palais royal
bien plus qu'un premier pas sur scène
c'est avant tout un pied dans l'histoire
qu'il déposera
on dit de Robert houden qu'il est le
père fondateur de la magie où le père de
la magie moderne parce qu'il est en
quelque sorte le premier à avoir donné
ses lettres de noblesse à la magie la du
fait que ce soit considéré comme le père
de la magie moderne c'est la magie qu'on
fait encore aujourd'hui Robert Houdain
et le type qui a décidé de rendre la
magie honnête grâce aux soirées
fantastiques il a créé grâce à ses
spectacles des événements il a été en
quelque sorte une sorte de directeur
marketing avant l'heure parce que il a
créé un mouvement où il y avait une
attente il a répondu à un besoin du
public d'être impressionné d'être
émerveillé surtout à une époque où on
était en quête de culture de loisirs et
finalement d'émerveillement et donc il a
répondu à cette attente de par tous les
mécanismes qu'il a créé et c'est devenu
en quelque sorte une institution à part
entière après des semaines à répéter les
textes de chacune de ces expériences
avec un pianiste et un travail minutieux
de la mise en scène le magicien était
fin prêt pour l'ouverture de son théâtre
ses deux fils Emile et Eugène tous deux
âgés de 14 ans et 8 ans ont eux aussi
vécu un véritable baptême du feu il
jouait un rôle prépondérant dans la mise
en place des tours et avait chacun des
tâches extrêmement délicates et précises
à assurer
il avait créé donc les soirées
fantastiques alors et là il a recréé un
petit salon mondain alors c'était un
petit théâtre voilà au Palais Royal et
donc il avait tout un petit décor mais
c'est ça ressemblait pas un décor de
spectacle ça ressemble à un décor un peu
comme celui-ci c'est-à-dire un décor
d'appartement et il avait un guéridon
une table un salon un bouquet de fleurs
comme les gens à l'époque déjà
appartements haussmanniens avaient leur
leur mobilier et donc ça changeait tout
parce que les gens se retrouvaient à la
maison comme chez eux et c'est là où il
a mis son abus son habit de soirée pour
dire je suis magicien je ne veux pas
vous tromper je ne vous manipule pas je
vous présente du spectacle et c'est ça
qui est absolument fondamental dans
Robert Wood Robert Houdin alors il est
habillé en frac en que depuis mais
c'était le le
costume de l'époque et ça ça changeait
tout parce que tout d'un coup les gens
découvrir le même le même type de
vêtements que qu'ils avaient eux-mêmes
voilà et quand on voit un magicien
s'habillant que de PI
inévitablement sans le savoir il imite
Robert houden mais ou d'un fuit sans
doute le premier à adopter une tenue
propre à la prestidigitation composée de
poches secrètes mais là encore personne
ne s'imaginait que son costume
d'apparence commune à celui que portait
les spectateurs eux-mêmes pouvaient
porter des secrets de dissimulation de
plus son attitude donnait l'impression
qu'ils étaient les invités privilégiées
d'un autre distingué et Robert houden
est venu en quelque sorte présenter la
magie sur scène à des gens qui payaient
un billet pour venir la voir la magie et
donc sa magie a été rapidement perçue
comme quelque chose d'aussi artistique
que la musique le théâtre la danse
Robert Gaudin il a cette capacité à
mêler le meilleur de tous les mondes
avec évidemment ce qu'il dégage l'aura
qu'il dégage la tenue évidemment le ton
est finalement toute la technique qu'il
va apporter à son tour en gros il met le
fond au service de la forme et
vice-versa il avait un tour avec des
Verts avec des mouchoirs avec un oranger
avec des horloges mais tous ces objets
on pouvait les retrouver à la maison et
là ça devait pour les gens ça devenait
un véritable miracle parce qu'ils
avaient le même vert le même le même
orangé à la maison et là ça devenait
vraiment magique donc ça a été le début
de la considération de la magie en tant
qu'accord donc on a commencé à percevoir
la magie comme quelque chose voilà qui
demande qui demandait une discipline qui
demandait une rigueur que ce n'est pas
tout le monde qui pouvait le faire donc
ça a vraiment donné ces lettres de
noblesse à la magie et ça on doit à
Robert houden mais c'est très loin
d'être le seul talent de Robert houden
magicien avait la faculté d'être
également un scientifique passionné par
les technologies et les sciences
modernes et ce sont ces compétences dans
ce domaine qu'il a mis au service de sa
magie
scientifique je considère que les
meilleurs magiciens sont souvent des
scientifiques c'est-à-dire que il
s'appuie sur le sur la logique pour
créer de des choses illogiques et c'est
assez
c'est assez vrai dans toute l'histoire
de la magie très souvent Robert boudin
évoquait des phénomènes scientifiques
lorsqu'ils présentaient ces numéros et
je pense par exemple à la suspension
était réelle qui est un numéro où
Monsieur Oudin donné l'illusion de
mettre son fils en lévitation donc son
fils se retrouvait en quelque sorte en
suspension dans les airs sur un balai et
Robert houden plaçait un récipient en
dessous de son fils avec un liquide et
il prétendait que les vapeurs des terres
étaient ce qui produisait la lévitation
ici évidemment c'est pas ce qui se
produisait donc tout le ce discours
scientifique était là en quelque sorte
pour faire rêver mais ça crédibilisait
sa magie et sa
ça donnait un aspect scientifique à la
magie ce qui était très novateur et ce
qui est très inspirant pour moi comme
illusionniste j'utilise un peu la même
stratégie il s'agit là de l'illusion la
plus sensationnelle de l'époque les
terres faisaient beaucoup parler la
communauté scientifique et le
retentissement de cette illusion fut
tellement immense qu'une partie de la
population accusée ou d'un de mettre en
danger la santé de son fils et
encourager la police à lui interdire de
faire ce tour autrement dit des
personnes croyaient réellement que les
terres pouvait faire l'éviter les
plagiats de cette expérience furent
nombreux si nombreux qu'un an plus tard
ou d'un présenter une version encore
plus sophistiquée au point qu'elle ne
fut jamais égalé mais ces travaux sur
l'électricité ont quand même été majeurs
et évidemment ça servait très bien sa
magie là on peut imaginer à une époque
où l'électricité n'est pas connu de voir
un arc électrique les gens évidemment
étaient fascinés étaient émerveillés de
voir ça et ça s'apparentait évidemment
des pouvoirs magiques on donne un as
magique à quelque chose de de
technologie quelque chose de méconnu et
ça c'est très ça pique énormément la
curiosité du spectateur c'est une
multitude de tours de magie toujours
plus sensationnel les uns que les autres
que Robert Oudin présente à son public
durant les 7 années où se produit dans
son théâtre la bouteille inépuisable la
corne d'abondance le pâtissier du palais
royal où l'écrivain dessinateur une
multitude d'oeuvres magistrales dans
l'art de la magie ont porté la notoriété
de Robert Houdin au-delà de nos
frontières certains de ces automates ont
été exportés aux États-Unis par le
célèbre pity barnum le créateur de freak
show il s'est également produit devant
la reine d'Angleterre le roi de France
en Allemagne Belgique et bien d'autres
encore
laissez-moi vous parler de la seconde
vue dont Robert Houdain est considéré
comme le créateur lors de ce tour il
bandait les yeux de son fils Émile qui
pouvait ensuite décrire avec précision
tous les objets que les spectateurs
présentés à son père ce tour qui donnait
l'illusion que son fils était doté de
pouvoir médiumniques a été repris et
détournée par de grands artistes tels
que le couple miroska artiste célèbre
dans les années 50 pour leur tour de
télépathie
comme vous pouvez le voir Robert Houda a
été une grande si ce n'est la plus
grande source d'inspiration pour les
illusionnistes et même les plus modernes
d'entre eux
[Musique]
le plus grand spectacle que j'ai monté
ça s'appelait le
la clé des mystères alors la queue des
mystères c'était l'intérieur de château
et tout le décor du château c'était les
objets de mes numéros de magie il y
avait un lustre c'est un tour de magie
il y avait un escalier en colimaçon
c'est un tour de magie un canapé tour de
magie etc donc les gens rentrés dans un
décor de château et exactement comme
l'avait fait Robert roudain à l'époque
où il travaillait dans son petit salon
moi je travaillais à l'intérieur d'un
château je n'ai jamais utilisé des
objets qui n'appartient qu'à la magie
donc vous voyez par exemple à un moment
dans ce spectacle il y avait ce guéridon
cette bibliothèque ça ressemble à un
vrai guéridon et une vraie bibliothèque
et donc c'est c'est là où Robert Houdin
m'a énormément inspiré parce que j'avais
compris que si lui il avait réussi à à
fasciner les gens avec des objets usuels
et leur raconter des véritables
histoires et bien j'ai fait la même
chose voilà pour moi Robert houden est
définitivement ce qu'on peut appeler une
inspiration j'ai une passion pour la
science pour la physique notamment
depuis longtemps lorsque je cherchais
comment comment je peux utiliser la
science pour bonifier ma magie c'est là
où les travaux de Robert houden sont
devenus extrêmement inspirants pour moi
ils ont eu un impact majeur dans mon
parcours dans mon évolution comme
illusionniste non seulement certains
numéros en particulier je le mentionnais
la suspension était réelle moi-même dans
mes numéros je présente parfois des des
accessoires un peu
à la fine pointe de la technologie et
j'essaie de je présente ses accessoires
c'est ses objets comme quelque chose qui
peut provoquer de la magie ou du moins
qui qui des objets qui sont
l'instigateur de phénomènes
scientifiques méconnus dans un numéro
par exemple que que par le passé je
donnais l'illusion de me téléporter d'un
côté de la scène à un autre et quand je
présentais ce numéro je parlais de
l'intrication quantique ce phénomène par
lequel les morceaux d'une même entité
restent liés même si on les sépare par
une grande distance donc c'est un peu la
même stratégie que ce que faisait
monsieur Oudin avec avec les terres
l'idée ici la même c'est d'utiliser un
phénomène scientifique qui est réel mais
plutôt méconnu par le grand public et
d'utiliser en quelque sorte cette cette
méconnaissance pour pour faire rêver les
gens l'approche de Robert Houdin de de
présenter sa magie comme quelque chose à
la limite entre la science et la magie
parce que la ligne parfois est fine et
c'est sur cette ligne que j'essaie
d'être lorsque je présente mes numéros
en suivant les traces de Monsieur houden
il n'a joué que s'étend dans son théâtre
du Palais Royal pour ensuite consacrer
la majeure partie de son temps dans sa
maison familiale à côté de Blois au
prieuré c'est dans cette maison
familiale qu'il a minutieusement étudié
l'électricité de ses découvertes il va
créer bon nombre d'inventions plus
épatantes les unes que les autres dont
nous avons encore l'usage à ce jour
Robert boudin est très connu comme
magicien il a été un peu moins comme
comme inventeur comme scientifique et
pourtant il a des grandes inventions à
son actif il est il est l'inventeur de
la domotique qui en quelque sorte
l'ancêtre des smart home donc les
maisons connectées à l'époque il avait
toutes ces horloges électriques dans son
domaine relié à un même régulateur
électrique ce qui permettait de
synchroniser toutes ces horloges en
permanence ce qui était évidemment très
novateur pour pour l'époque on raconte
que dans son domaine il avait une
sonnette électrique et qui pouvait
ouvrir le portail de son domaine à
distance donc ça s'est transformé son
domaine pratiquement en parc
d'attraction pour les gens c'est lui qui
a inventé le plastron électrique des
esquimeurs il est l'inventeur du
compteur kilométrique qu'on utilise
encore de nos jours il a il a eu aussi
quelques tentatives pour créer utiliser
des arcs électriques pour s'éclairer
donc je pense il prenait un
filament de un fil de bambou je crois
sur lequel il enduisait de la poudre de
carbone ou quelque chose comme ça donc
ça fait un arc électrique avec lequel on
pouvait s'éclairer bon ça a duré pas
très longtemps quand quand l'ampoule a
filament de Thomas Edison est arrivé
quelques années plus tard évidemment
c'est ce qui a passé à l'histoire mais
n'empêche que Robert houden était un
pionnier comme homme de science en
utilisant l'électricité et en voyant
comment l'électricité pouvait
transformer nos vies par des inventions
comme celle qu'on utilise encore
aujourd'hui et dont Robert houden et
l'instigateur le reste de sa vie il le
consacrera principalement à
l'ophtalmologie en une année seulement
Robert houden crée cet instrument
permettant d'observer les organes de
l'oeil le pupillomètre afin de pouvoir
donner le diamètre d'une pupille ou
encore le dioxymètre
[Musique]
aujourd'hui Houdini c'est la référence
et l'image de lui dans une dans une cuve
d'eau les pieds attachés ou en train de
se libérer c'est iconique voilà
c'est-à-dire que Robert Houdart il avait
le savoir-faire mais encore faut-il le
faire savoir ou Lini quant à lui c'était
les moyens c'était les grandes affiches
c'était Hollywood dans votre théâtre en
quelque sorte puis j'étais un type qui
avait le sens de la communication voilà
marketing à fond il hésitait pas à faire
venir la presse ce qui est drôle c'est
que au départ
Houdini parce qu'on en parle faisait des
tours comme n'importe quel magicien des
tours de cartes et d'ailleurs il
reproduisait des tours d'autres
magiciens il était pas si bon
manipulateur que ça et en fait ils sont
en effet une spécialité
progressivement en faisant de l'évasion
et il a trouvé finalement le registre
auquel personne n'avait pensé et il
annoncé à l'intérieur et ce qui a fait
son son image de marque c'est qu'il
s'est spécialisé dans l'escapologie
l'art de l'évasion alors il faisait
attacher de toutes sortes de manières
attacher à des à des chaînes il
s'évadaient enfermé dans des mâles
suspendus par les pieds il avait cette
capacité à
multimédiatiser ses événements et à
faire dans chaque cas de chacune de ces
apparitions un événement à part entière
autre chose lorsqu'il arrivait dans une
ville il y avait par exemple des
affiches des petites annonces où ils
mettaient au défi les commerçants les
boulangers à venir le mettre des fiches
pas d'une évasion d'un défi magique en
quelque sorte et il était marqué c'est
très drôle dans le prospectus je
remplirai ce défi mais jamais dans un
cadre privé toujours dans un cadre
public au-delà de créer l'événement il
crée en fait le marketing actuel
comment et pourquoi je vais aller le
voir parce que je vais te t'offrir
quelque chose
qui n'existe pas à tel point que il est
devenu plus célèbre que Robert Houda
dans le monde entier petite anecdote
malencontreusement Houdini est venu
apporter des fleurs avec des des
présents plein les bras à l'aveu de
Robert Houdin et elle a gentiment
remercié en disant qu'elle voulait pas
recevoir ce gars qui qui avait pris le
nom de son mari
45 sur un troisième
les courants de la magie n'ont eu 16
d'évoluer en passant du close-up à la
street magie l'arrivée de la télévision
et de la théâtralisation des numéros et
des spectacles la magie est
définitivement devenue un art en
perpétuel évolution selon son époque et
ses nouvelles technologies mais
attention à ce qui se sert de l'illusion
pour faire croire au pouvoir surnaturel
et préférons plutôt la phrase de miroska
qui disait deux solutions sont possibles
un miracle ou un trucage s'il n'y a pas
de truc alors c'est formidable mais s'il
y en a un alors c'est encore plus fort
et voilà donc je me rappelle de cette
époque où Majax avait
fait comme Robert Houdin quoi parce que
une époque tout le monde parlait de
pouvoir surnaturel de gens qui pouvaient
Tordre des fusils des des cuillères à
distance c'est à dire que dans les
années 70
urique Geder arrivait en prétendant
avoir des pouvoirs surnaturels alors
qu'on savait sur nos annuaires de
magiciens qu'il était illusionniste
spécialiste tordeur de petites cuillères
donc ça nous faisait beaucoup rire sauf
jusqu'au jour on a vu que les gens ils
croyaient le mal de l'homme est en train
de ressortir de l'avant Robert Houdain
c'est-à-dire la manipulation de l'homme
sur l'homme j'ai un pouvoir sur vous
donc je peux vous soigner je peux vous
guérir je peux tordre les cuillères je
peux
parler avec les extraterrestres et là on
a eu un certain nombre de magiciens et
en France c'était que uniquement Gérard
Majax qui est venu combattre
c'est avec plein de détournement
d'attention je viens de suivre les
mouvements c'est de l'illusionisme et je
préférais vraiment je trouve que c'est
dommage quand on incite les enfants à
faire ça dans la France s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît c'est une mascarade
c'est de l'illusionnisme mais moi ça me
fait rire mais moi je trouve c'est
dommage qu'il y aurait galéré est-ce
qu'on peut faire une dernière expérience
parce que j'aimerais être ami avec
les années 90 ont donné naissance à la
Grande Illusion une magie qui rassemble
des millions de spectateurs notamment
grâce à la télévision cette période
représente un véritable tournant pour
l'histoire de la magie et pour ceux qui
la pratique c'est dans les années 90
d'ailleurs que j'ai commencé les
premières méga illusions la France à
l'époque était très peu
attaché à la magie c'était vraiment
considéré pour des
du comment je pourrais dire une
discipline pour les enfants pour amuser
les enfants la première méga illusion
que j'ai inventé c'était la lévitation
d'un hôtel de ville il y avait des
milliers de gens qui sont venus qui ont
vu leur hôtel de ville se soulever en
lévitation et redescendre comme une
partenaire au-delà de ça ça déclenchait
un électrochoc dans le mental des
Français c'est un système et c'est ça la
magie c'est pas pour les enfants la
magie il y a des magiciens qui
impressionnent lorsque vous regardez un
peu l'histoire de la magie c'est le cas
notamment de David Copperfield lui
typiquement dans son état il a il a
changé la donne parce que
il y a eu la télévision au-delà d'être
un excellent manipulateur de cartes un
passionné et mérite depuis l'âge de 7
ans il a eu cette chance d'être exposé
sur des grands network américain qui
l'ont fait connaître du monde entier
David Copperfield évidemment est arrivé
avec une j'allais dire une perfection
des mises en scène c'est à dire que
je sais pas comment il a réussi à aller
aussi loin sur la mise en scène alors
évidemment quand il est arrivé avec le
vol tout le monde est tombé par terre
parce qu'on le voyait vraiment voler
c'est à dire que moi quand j'ai vu le ce
qu'on appelle le fly en technique
magique que des centaines de magiciens à
travers le monde en fait
mais regardez David Copperfield vous le
voyez voler les autres vous les voyez
faire un numéro de magie ça n'a rien à
voir David Copperfield vole
son écriture poétique sa technique sa
mise en scène je crois pas que j'ai pas
vu grand chose d'aussi parfait sur le
plan artistique de ma vie si l'absolu
existait je dirais absolu c'était une
perfection incroyable
David Copperfield est en effet un des
plus grands illusionnistes contemporains
car il a su comme notre cher Robert
Houdin s'adapter à son époque que ce
soit d'un point de vue narratif mais
aussi technologique si Robert Houdain a
fait de la magie avec de l'horlogerie
David Copperfield a su faire de la
prestidigitation avec du cinéma sans
trahir de secret
rien n'est laissé au hasard le la
musique qui est choisie l'histoire qui a
raconté exactement comme un film avec un
début un milieu une fin qui fait une
guerre un effet WoW et finalement un
twist de fin il s'est fortement inspiré
de tous les films de cinéma qu'il avait
été impressionné et d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui il fait apparaître sur scène
une scoop volante un tyrannosaure rex
voilà une sorte d'hommage à la pop
culture
mais alors quelle sera la magie de
demain et je dirais même quels sont les
magies d'aujourd'hui on peut considérer
que le mentalisme est par exemple une
autre façon de créer la magie bien loin
de la grande illusion et même de la
prestidigitation avec pour outils
principal le cerveau aussi avec
l'apparition des réseaux sociaux nous
avons pu voir apparaître ne multitudes
de personnes pratiquant des tours
d'illusion en se servant de cette
accessibilité et de cette technologie
nouvelle pour trouver un réel public
sans jamais monter sur scène serait-ce
là un des nouveaux courants le nouveau
courant ce sont les magiciens qui auront
cette capacité à transformer la magie
digital en une magie finalement réelle
parce que finalement les trucages les
effets spéciaux tout le monde peut plus
ou moins en faire à partir du moment où
vous avez une très bonne application
mais en fait l'arsenic se présentait
devant un public et l'émerveiller
ressentir l'émotion je pense que elle
est là la Belgique demain finalement le
but de la magie c'est quoi c'est de
sortir de notre réalité et cette réalité
au final
c'est de de la prendre et de la modifier
pour que les magiciens puissent à
travers les années rester mettre de leur
art Robert Houdin passe les dernières
années de sa vie dans sa maison au
Prieuré à côté de Blois sa ville natale
c'est dans cette maison entièrement
aménagée par ses inventions qu'il
s'éteindra le 13 juin 1871 des suites
d'une pneumonie laissant ainsi derrière
lui l'héritage de son incroyable génie
sa fille églantine racontera que lors de
son dernier soupir toutes les horloges
et les cloches de la maison dans un
ensemble impressionnant comptèrent les
10 coups de l'heure de sa mort comme un
dernier adieu à celui qui leur avait
donné la vie et qu'elle devait suivre
dans l'éternité
de son décès dans la presse provoqua une
véritable déferlande d'hommage
absolument innombrable l'enterrement a
eu lieu le 16 juin à 10h30 à l'église de
Saint-Gervais on raconte qu'il y avait
tant de monde que tous n'ont pas pu
pénétrer à l'intérieur de l'église il
repose désormais dans le cimetière de
Blois où sa femme Olympe fit ériger un
mausolée orné du médaillon de marbre
blanc représentant le profil de houda à
toutes les personnes qui regarderont ce
documentaire allez voir des magiciens
sortez parce que évidemment voir un tour
un effet flash comme ça c'est très bien
mais en fait il faut le vivre c'est
comme une attraction dans un parc de
loisirs il faut vivre le roller coaster
pour ressentir les émotions à la magie
c'est pareil c'est on emmène quelque
part pour te raconter une histoire et
finalement casser avec cette réalité et
savoir que finalement le rêve il est là
il est présent et les magiciens ont
cette capacité à encore à travers des
années à nous impressionner et à nous
faire sortir de notre quotidien la
France est le pays de la magie grâce à
Robert Audin donc rappelons-le et
restons le pays de la magie parce qu'on
a des talents pour ça
merci pour tout merci de continuer de
changer ma vie merci surtout à Robert
Houdin
[Musique]